hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute wirklich mal wieder auf simon
later in der letzten folge haben wir ja
sonne
was haben wir da noch mal gemacht was
habe ich getan
das war ja schon ein wenig verstört
diese ziege deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht da nicht den krieger alter
deswegen habe ich euch in den
kommentaren gefragt ob er eventuell noch
andere sachen habe die man eventuell die
machen kann und da wurde mir dieser tour
im mv
er ist eine ziege drin mir wurde gesagt
wenn ich da hoch gehe kann ich nachher
zu gott werden ich weiß was es hier drin
die küsten
die berühren sich die zum baguette die
man noch ein stück du bleibst und jetzt
mal einfach hier noch ein bisschen hoch
sie ist wieder aufgestanden bleibt genau
da ich gehe jetzt mal hoch und schaue
was ich hier drin rom wo sind wir das
ist mir gerade ein bisschen unheimlich
alles ich glaub ich geh wieder zurück
schön dass ich nicht zurückgehen kann
ich hier irgendwas kann ich nicht
danke ziegel dass du immer so produktiv
bist kann ich nicht einfach die mit vao
schaut mal ich kann die kiste
theoretisch
tschuldigung dahin comedy verneigen sich
vor mir wie süße außer dir die hab ich
ja gerade irgendwie bleibt da im moment
kann ich die anderen auch mal eben hier
brosch auch nicht was doch wenn man bei
mir und damit mit beugen und tom kitt
noch sehe ich ganz schön aus aber ich
weiß nicht was passiert wenn nichts
anscheinend kann ich mit her drücken
irgendwas machen aber ich weiß nicht das
was ist habe ich ist hier irgendwie was
das tue ich nicht
ich glaube ich töte gerade ein paar
ziegen und es ruckelt zum glück gar
nicht spielt luca einmal gold simi later
und dann ist einfach jeder tod aber wir
können zum glück oder lassen es nicht
schlecht wenn ich hier durchlaufen und
zum glück meint ec das alles hinkriegt
mit den ganzen siegen ist zum zungenkuss
an
was kannst du eigentlich nichts gemacht
wurde auch geschrieben dass ich dir
jetzt die steuern kann aber ich glaube
das funktioniert nicht so richtig ich
kann die nicht mal mit der zunge
mitnehmen was ist denn hier ach guck mal
jetzt habe ich eine auf mir drauf legen
gehasst bin ich irgendwie noch besonders
stark
ich glaube ich bin tatsächlich muss die
kiste hin habe ich andere fähigkeiten
als dass ich jetzt einfach mit eher
drücken
ich glaube mehr kann ich einfach nicht
machen ich probier gerade mal so viele
ziegen wie möglich genau hier auf der
straße zu spawnen dass wenn jetzt da
hinten wieder eltern bekommen die wäsche
schauen können was bei gottes ist
wirklich schon schließlich muss noch
indirekt ich muss sie irgendwie weg und
irrt das war massaker in der tat ich
staune noch mehr ziegeln ich könnte mich
nicht daran hindern
ich fühle mich scheiße wenn ich die hier
die ganze zeit fallen lasse lkw du bist
nicht so stark verletzt
vielleicht ist er auch stärker ich muss
das video mal hier beenden weil die
frames gerade bei 5 sind zur erklärung
das ist sehr wenig verschoben wir meinen
nicht ziel bei unseren leuten hier bei
den können wir aber kann ich ja ich kann
die ziege mitnehmen ich werde das video
hier trotz beenden weil es ruckelt nur
noch schaut euch das an das ist einfach
nicht mehr schön wenn ihr noch mehr so
ideen habt wie ich auch solche züge
machen kann irgendwie einem hochhaus
geben und mit einer party habe ich auch
was gelesen oder so schreibt ohne den
kommentaren wir sehen uns dann in